o e um dia a mandala realmente da
trajetória da vida leva um grande abalo
e aí a gente descobre como disse amon já
pouco aqui que o caminho que estava
caminhando era pra buscar uma coisa lá
na frente mas na verdade o caminho está
embaixo dos teus pés a onde tu tá agora
o tempo eu descobri aí nesse momento é
onde estão os meus pés naquele momento e
aí descobri naquela época também uma
coisa totalmente que faz parte da nossa
essência da nossa natureza somos
permanentemente em permanentes
eu já tava aí com 41 anos eu brinco que
talvez aquela frase a vida começa aos 40
estava fazendo um ano de idade então tá
tudo bem sobre isso é porque realmente
uma coisa tão simples né
é como a gente sabe onde eu cheguei aqui
em paz fundo tinha sol depois choveu de
noite hoje está só isso é em permanência
ea gente essa constância por isso essa
importância tanto da gente se dá conta
de que a gente está nesse momento mas
naquele dia eu começava naquele momento
era um dia específico eu quero trazer
aqui um grande processo de desconstrução
era um dia normal de almoço com a minha
filha sair com 10 e 12 anos a júlia
rafaela e que na verdade eu fui aprender
que era um dia normal o tico eu dava pra
elas naquela refeição é o que eu escolhi
eu fazia as compras é o que define o que
é ser de almoço uma alimentação que era
assim uma caixinha de frango congelado
processado com os desenhos na frente uma
massa que ficava a gente até voltava no
forno para não fritar a gente dava uma
massa instantânea que ficava pronto em
três minutos então imagina o que tinha
lhe para ficar pronto em três minutos e
o líquido que eu dava gelado e insistiu
que elas tomassem durante a refeição era
um suco que vinha no pacote que durava
de seis meses a um ano no supermercado
então tudo aquilo era
atualmente é a nona à normalidade que eu
vivia e que eu fui descobrir assim como
eu descobri também que joão de barro na
frente dessa mesma mesa eu moro no sexto
andar
ainda dentro da cidade não tem vários
postes de luz fazem casinhas de joão de
barro isso já vão contar então quase
seis anos cinco anos e pouco eu já
assisti mais de dez obras desses livros
passarinhos que durou mais ou menos
quase 30 dias para eles fazerem toda a
família deles e até aí eu nunca tinha
prestado atenção eu já morava nesse
endereço há pelo menos cinco anos então
isso é normal 11 né e provavelmente esse
é o risco da gente vivesse em prestar
atenção no agora e isso é que pode estar
trazendo um panorama que a gente está
vivendo de desequilíbrio mas porque de
construção porque eu iniciava uma
desconstrução naquele ano eu completava
24 anos da entrada então na faculdade de
medicina hipócrates mais uma vez aqui 18
anos que eu trabalhava com uma das
doenças mais freqüentes que é o diabetes
mellitus e obesidade
e apesar disso eu não tinha me dado
conta e não tinha eu digo que talvez eu
fingia que não sabia porque como é que
eu não tinha aquele conhecimento que
aqueles conservantes que aqueles
acidulantes que aqueles corantes
daqueles alimentos que eu estava
ingerindo e estava dando para aquelas
pessoas em que eu estava ensinando o que
era a vida eu não sabia o quanto faziam
mal e quando fazem parte do que a gente
pode chamar na verdade muito mais do que
o panorama de saúde que a gente vive
hoje um panorama de doença
por exemplo se a gente pegar um dado bem
brasileiro do ano passado a gente estava
tendo em 2014
quase três cidades de passo fundo de
diagnóstico de novos câncer de
diferentes tipos no ano de 2014
a doença então que eu trabalhava a gente
tem uma
pelos dados da organização mundial de
saúde um dardo kindle
1.030 gente vai ter mais de 200 milhões
novos casos de diabetes diabetes essa
totalmente ligado em grande parte ela
tem sim uma relação genética mas a
grande parte é o estilo de vida é que eu
como é que eu estou fazendo no meu agora
então essas duas doenças por exemplo são
totalmente relacionadas com a minha vida
normal ática ou não a gente tem um outro
dado bastante assustador que é pessoas
hoje no mundo inteiro com mais de 60
anos estão tomando pelo menos 2
medicamentos ou para dormir a
hipertensão ou diabetes e para acordar
com o meu brincou para a pressão
arterial para o coração bater então essa
é a nossa realidade normática e é o que
a gente tem feito na verdade acho que
jogar e mostrou se muito bem
é tendo um grande empenho na prevenção e
ela vai ser necessário a gente vai
precisar de uns bons 100 anos de fazer
prevenção pedir prevenção através do
diagnóstico precoce
a gente vai precisar de muito tempo
ainda a gente tem muita doença e muito
jovem muito adulto jovem para
diagnosticar porque é isso que a gente
vem vivendo nos últimos anos mas na
verdade a gente já sabe o que está
causando essas doenças então a gente tem
que começar o mesmo tempo essa mesma
investimento que a gente faz no
diagnóstico da doença em evitar porque
as gerações depois de nós já tão fadados
a serem mais doenças aqueles números são
vão ser cada vez pior
isso já é dado estatístico então a gente
sabe que a gente está vivendo mais por
exemplo isso é um dado de saúde é bom
estamos vendo mais a idade média saiu o
ano passado brasileira 70 72 anos mas a
gente está vivendo mais
as coxas com mais doença a gente está
vivendo mais por causa da tecnologia
a gente está vivendo mais por causa do
avanço do medicamento a gente tem vindo
mais porque a gente está controlando
mais a mortalidade infantil também então
isso é um dado de saúde muito importante
mas por exemplo a gente sabe que a
grande parte da verba de saúde do
governo
gasta nos últimos dois anos de vida das
pessoas com internações hospitalares com
o uso de medicamentos com as uti com
casas de repouso hoje todas as
emergências dos hospitais públicos de
porto alegre certamente vão estar
lotadas e não tendo vaga e por que que a
gente não aplica esse mesmo é dessa
mesma forma lá quando os pais vão gerar
os filhos né
é o que a gente fala então de
epigenética e assim a gente vai poder
ter as próximas gerações não com esses
números que a gente já sabe que estão
definidos mas tem um cuidado bem
importante nessa missão de buscar esse
equilíbrio assim que eu acho que a gente
tem que ter a gente já tá indo
misturando as coisas que é a questão do
modismo né então surge aí a moda da
dieta ideal
e na verdade o que a gente tem visto
tanto na ciência como nessa observação
milenar toda é que a gente não vai
precisar sair da cidade sair do centro
urbano para poder ter saúde a gente pode
conseguir onde a gente tá eu por exemplo
brinco que eu montei o meu himalaia na
sala da minha casa né então além de ver
o joão de barro fazendo as suas casinhas
eu descobri que em porto alegre tem uma
feira orgânica naquela época eu já
estava fazendo 20 anos
agora nem cinco anos nesse processo já
tem uma feira orgânica através da minha
casa que a gente pode a pena a gente
pode de bicicleta botei um filtro de
barro dentro da minha casa eu fiz uma
pequena horta orgânica então a gente não
vai precisar provavelmente substituir
tirar coisas da nossa alimentação
inventar dietas de de como virá o motivo
ea gente vai de novo viver uma nova moda
porque essa capacidade essa alimentação
natural que a gente vem fazendo nos
trouxe até aqui nos possibilitou ter
essa evolução desse corte frontal que
inventa tudo isso ea gente é sem dúvida
pelo menos conhecida tal a espécie mais
evoluída mais evoluída e esquecida de
como chegamos até aqui e aquela mesa por
exemplo da minha casa que começou com
todos aqueles alimentos eu combinei
naquela época com a minha filha
né que aqueles três alimentos eu
realmente tinha sido um tsunami muito
forte da mandala e que eu não ia
conseguir mais comprá-los aqueles
alimentos e o resto eu ia te entendido
que até aí eu não tinha entendido muita
coisa que eu ia aprender e aos poucos a
gente ia mudando o que aconteceu nesse
tempo é que a gente realmente consegue
ter hoje uma alimentação talvez em
grande parte quase 80% de alimentação
integral ou seja que não seja refinada
que que não seja industrializada e se a
gente conseguir orgânica ou seja que os
a gente consiga um alimento uma verdura
que não tem agrotóxico e ainda que seja
realmente a natureza mas eu digo pra
elas né
faz parte também o alimento emocional
por isso essa coisa de não ter um
radicalismo a gente vai continuar
comendo elas continuam comendo uma pizza
com as amigas continuam comendo fazendo
o brigadeiro pra comer de colher
isso é a gente não precisa abandonar
isso isso a gente chama alimento
emocional e aí vem uma questão assim que
talvez se tornou a minha grande pergunta
naquele momento ela é até hoje eu
realmente acompanhei nesses últimos 20
anos da minha vida
muita bastante campanha com a
sustentabilidade do meio ambiente acho
que a gente realmente deve tá
conseguindo alguma coisa
a mídia fala bastante disso mas o quanto
a gente está realmente investindo nessa
sustentabilidade do ser humano quer
dizer o que vai adiantar praias limpas
se a gente vai estar todo mundo aos 60
anos tomando pelo menos 2 medicamentos e
precisando então de todo um suporte com
diagnóstico de doenças que não vão nem o
símbolo até nos impedir de a gente
chegar nessas praias né ea gente já
falou muito aqui dessa interligação que
a gente tem a gente é essa natureza nós
somos o é um relembrar realmente e aí
assim a gente é construído diariamente
esse é um processo muito lindo de
entender
eu tive que voltar lá para os livros de
fisiologia que eu tinha deixado de lado
neto tinha entrado nesse processo de
aprender a curar e e depois do terceiro
ano
tudo então como é que a doença se tu não
conecta mais com a fisiologia lindo ler
de novo e ver que realmente ela precisa
de tudo isso precisa da água preciso
sais minerais é assim que ela funciona
isto vai construir por exemplo uma
parede de alvenaria do vailatti jolo tu
vai usar areia tu vai usar cimento que
quer dizer que se a minha cela ela o meu
corpo é feito mais de 50% de água como é
que eu vou dar um líquido para ela que
tem um corante um conservante e que
tenha que ser como é que ele vai sair de
mim se ele dura um ano na prateleira do
supermercado eu brinco que a gente não
tem um aparato fisiológico não está
escrito lá no livro que eu tenha um
produto uma na primeira fisiologia um
elemento que degrade produtos da
indústria alimentícia e se é esse
alimento aquilo que está escrito ali na
bula dos alimentos e ingredientes 2
pontos monte de nomes em vai ficar de
alguma forma em mim e vai atrapalhar a
função dessas ela porque ela na verdade
pra ser construída precisa de outro
elemento os mesmos que estão na natureza
ea gente é destruído nome diz construído
na verdade o dia inteiro então que lindo
a gente poder entender isso e oferecer
praça é se ela se construiu hoje no dia
de hoje eu preciso um pouco da água para
ela é preciso dar uma fruta para ela é
preciso dar o alimento que é porque
amanhã algumas delas vão ser realmente
diz construídas e aí elas vão ser
reposta
e é isso que a gente não faz ou então
vão se diferenciar e aí a gente vai ter
um câncer ou vão formar um órgão novo no
nosso abdômen que a obesidade abdominal
e aí eu vou ter o diabetes
e aí o que eu queria o que eu desenvolvi
ea partir daí apliquei na minha vida e
hoje compartilha na minha consulta
nesses cinco anos e foi forçado muito
com uma medicina que eu escolher entre
as várias que naquele ano então eu fui
procurar na época
naquela época o que se falava de saúde
no mundo então as clínicas que falavam
de medicina integral no mundo hardware
maior clínico mas realmente quando eu li
uma ciência que
o nome em sânscrito significa ayurveda
que é exatamente a ciência da vida e
fechava muito com aquilo que eu tinha
estudado muito durante 20 anos na minha
fisiologia e explicar vá à má a formação
das grandes partes de doença de goiás
que eu vou estudar então com a aplicação
do herdeiro na minha vida e hoje na
minha prática eu desenvolvi e aplico e
prescrevo que eu chamo caminho do meio
no sentido de que a gente vai se grande
parte do meu tempo 50% ou até um pouco
mais eu colocar uma alimentação integral
uma alimentação natural uma alimentação
orgânica eu vou certamente mudar esses
números e eu voltei equilíbrio e os 20 e
os 30 por cento ou 50 é exatamente esse
elemento emocional não precisa deixar de
comer aquela torta da casa da amiga que
vai tomar um chá que ela te convida faz
com tanto carinho tanto amor e vai
entregar amor porque de repente tem
lactose o açúcar ou refinado porque se a
maior parte do tempo cuida de tir
do ponto de vista físico aquele alimento
emocional vai ser tão importante também
e aí eu queria realmente prescrever e eu
acho que essa prescrição não vai
precisar do meu receituário e nem vai
precisar que vocês anotem o que desse
nessa nessa ala nessa nessa minha nesse
meu abalo da mandala eu venho através do
estudo através da ciência e dessa
observação milenar construindo como uma
prescrição básica de saúde para um ser
humano hoje para a gente mudar né com os
nossos pés no agora mas que a gente
consiga ali na frente mudar esses nomes
que a gente está vivendo
e aí a gente vai garantir a célula
humana tem uma estimativa de vida de 120
anos com 120 anos e apresentar saudável
tem vários povos no mundo estudados hoje
onde a média de idade é 80 e tem mais de
100 anos e eles estão lá saudáveis e têm
orgulho de dizer sua idade
e aí pra isso é isso bebe água o corpo
humano precisa de água não beberam hoje
vão beber água
é necessário colocar água no teu dia
então começa a prescrição não deixa de
beber água
o segundo item é da maior parte do seu
tempo eu brinco assim que são sete
refeições são sete dias da semana três
refeições por dia 21 por semana
se pelo menos 15 ou 16 delas de colocar
um alimento que venha da natureza que
nem tudo que não seja industrializado
refinado e que se possível isto tem uma
filha ecológicos do pode já ter já colou
já mora no lugar de jackson tem o
paraíso na terra ou seja tem um pomar em
casa uma feira orgânica ainda não tem
tudo isso usa esses alimentos e é claro
te permite o contato o outro através
também o papel da comida de comercialino
que de repente tu vai de novo numa
celebração de uma festa e lá tem alguma
coisa como eu brigo de repente vai numa
cidade do interior ea pessoa fez um bolo
com uma com leite de uma vaquinha
orgânica e deco não vai comer porque de
repente não pode comer lactose neova na
casa de alguém de novo ela faz aquela
torna isso não come porque açúcar
refinado não esquece do alimento
emocional
a idéia é não ter esse radicalismo a
gente não abandonar isso é uma conquista
nossa
de novo o sono é fundamental mas para a
gente ter um sono reparador
o senhor é um é assim fisiologicamente
um divisor de águas de saúde pra gente
eu não posso comer uma pizza às onze da
noite eu dou uma informação pro meu
corpo totalmente impossível pra ele ele
resolver isso então come até às 20 horas
como quando tiver fome e ali pra e assim
ah ah ah não menos importante do que
isso
mas para poder utilizar os alimentos
essa prescrição termina assim não deixa
de se movimentar a gente é um corpo em
movimento não deixem de testar o
equilíbrio a gente pode chegar aos 120
anos com o mesmo equilíbrio se alonga e
dorme bem e aí eu queria finalizar que a
grande palavra que traduz tudo isso é
muito mais do que educação é também
educação é intuição é conhecimento mas é
principalmente consciência
o relembrar daquilo que a gente
simplesmente esqueceu
mas tudo isso que eu falei a gente sabia
quando estava de quatro patas a gente
esqueceu quando ficou de duas brigadas
tudo